joining us today secretary of energy
jennifer granholm
secretary of homeland security alejandro
mayorkas
and deputy secretary of energy uh david
turk i since secretary granholm and
majorcas have been here before i will
skip their introductions but i do want
to note that deputy secretary turk was
previously
the deputy executive director of the
international energy agency
during the obama biden administration he
coordinated international technology and
clean energy efforts at doe
and served a special assistant to the
president and senior director at the
national security council
they obviously have a lot on their
plates today but have agreed to stay for
a few questions
uh with that i will turn it over to
secretary grantham thank you
all right thanks jen um
so uh the white house and the department
of energy have been
leading an interagency response to the
colonial pipeline
hack and fortunately the interagency
response is bringing a lot of
expertise and resources and authorities
from across
the federal government we've been
working around the clock since friday
uh to to help colonial friday night when
we learned of course to hope
to help colonial return the pipeline to
normal
operation as quickly and as safely and
as securely
as possible i would note that
last night uh one of colonial's
major lines resumed operation under
manual control
while the um existing inventory is
available along with some of the
smaller lines that are spurs off of the
major lines they are getting those up
and running
many of you are aware that colonial
announced
yesterday that they fully expect to
substantially
restore operations by the end of this
week
now i've had several conversations with
uh the ceo
of colonial and who has indicated
that by close of business tomorrow
colonial will be in a position to make
the full
restart decision but even after that
decision
is made it will take a few days to ramp
up
operations this pipeline has never been
shut down before it travels
great distances there is fuel in the
pipe
and then there is fuel the off take from
the refineries that have to be added
so it will take a few days to be up and
running
but our interagency effort um is going
to be on it all the way and let me tell
you what that has looked like
so far starting uh this weekend
my team began multiple daily calls with
colonial senior
executives dave turk uh leading those
and um those calls have enabled us to
share information across the
federal government to keep us fully in
sync with their progress and to let them
know what what
resources we can bring to bear um we've
spoken today
and yesterday with several governors
offices in the affected
areas from the south and the
mid-atlantic
um they're obviously understandably
concerned uh with reports of gas
stations
running out of fuel and they want this
pipeline restarted restarted as do
we all we are going to continue to
assess
impacts along the east coast and
uh the in particular the parts of the
southeast
using the information and analysis from
the energy information agency which is
part of the
uh interagency combined efforts and
other federal partners
we're using um these conversations and
that information to inform the federal
decision
making with our federal partners around
steps to mitigate these supply
impacts and disruptions so on sunday
afternoon
some of you are aware that the
department of transportation
issued an hours of service waiver which
provides greater flexibility to drivers
who are transporting
gas and diesel and jet fuel across
17 states as well as the district of
columbia d.o.t
also moved to temporarily relax
some of its workforce requirements and
monitoring
so that we can make sure that we have
the personnel
online in these in these places and with
the drivers
this morning the environmental
protection agency
issued a waiver of the blend of fuels
for the affected
states to allow us to use non-compliant
fuel and boost available supply where
it's needed
further the department of
transportation's federal
rail administration is working to enlist
rail operators in an effort to transport
fuel
from uh ports inland to and from and
um i spoke as well with chairman glick
of the federal energy regulatory
commission of ferc
this morning he is positioned to issue
ferc his position to issue orders
quickly um
to direct the pipeline to prioritize
fuel to the areas that are most in need
once the pipeline
is up and running so in short we're
looking at every option we have
across federal government the federal
government and all of the
agencies and in the meantime i do want
to say this
that we expect that gas station
owners are are and should act
responsibly we will have no tolerance
for
price gouging federal and state
officials
will be investigating those actions if
they see price gouging
and we are urging consumers to report
any
price gouging to their state attorneys
general
and still i want to be clear that these
states
who are impacted even with the
um the turning on of the pipeline system
they still may feel a supply crunch
as colonial fully resumes so um
but the american people can feel assured
that this administration is working with
the company to get it resumed as soon as
possible and
and as um one other warning i guess
uh let me emphasize that much as there
um
was no cause for say hoarding toilet
paper at the beginning of the pandemic
there should be no cause for
hoarding gasoline uh especially in light
of the fact that the pipeline
should be substantially operational by
the end of this week
and over the weekend so at the same time
it certainly is a reminder that we need
to take a hard look
at uh how we need to harden our
necessary infrastructure
and that includes cyber threats and as
anne newberger
who was here yesterday and told you this
administration
is taking an all hands on deck approach
to
uh enhancing our cyber defenses and
secretary mayorkas
is here to tell us a bit about uh what
he's doing on that
thank you very much um secretary grant
home and let me
let me pick up on uh something that the
secretary said that i think is very
important to emphasize on
on friday this ransomware attack became
public
uh saturday morning the president was
briefed
and immediately directed an all of
government effort
and immediately we executed
on the president's direction the
department of energy the department of
transportation
uh dod in terms of its logistics
capabilities
uh the epa and of course the department
of homeland security
uh and and others the
the direction was to bring our
capabilities and our resources to bear
our expertise and whatever we can do
to be poised should any of those
capabilities be called upon
or be able to deliver much needed
resources
we in the department of homeland
security for example began working
immediately with the department of
transportation
to be ready should any request for a
jones act waiver
be made to us to allow a foreign flag
vessel
to deliver fuel should that need arise
and of course
that need is not necessarily yet
confirmed
but we want it to be poised at the
president's direction
to be uh ready and to be able to act uh
immediately
the the attack that colonial pipe
suffered is a ransomware attack uh
that uh threat of ransomware is uh
certainly by no means new as a matter of
fact last week
i spoke at an event sponsored by the
united states chamber of commerce
about the gravity of the threat
more than 350 million dollars in losses
are attributable
to ransomware attacks this year that's a
more than 300 percent
increase over last year's uh
victimization of companies and there's
no company too small
to suffer a ransomware attack we are
seeing increasingly small and
medium-sized
businesses suffer a ransomware attack
and we are bringing in the department of
homeland security
uh our capabilities to bear through the
cyber security
and infrastructure security agency or
cisa
as it is commonly known uh we are
in the lead in the public-private
partnership in an
all-of-government effort to raise the
cyber hygiene
of private industry and of course within
the federal
dot gov environment as well
we share information between the public
and private sectors
we share best practices we have cyber
security directors
to actually uh be on site at a company's
facilities uh to assess it to make
recommendations
and to direct it with respect to
voluntarily
directed to raise its cyber hygiene and
how it can best
do so um this threat
is not imminent it is upon us the
colonial pipe
ransomware attack is a stark example
of what we have been saying for some
time
now and quite frankly when i served as
the deputy secretary
of homeland security in the second term
of the obama biden administration
we were focused on it then and so we are
bringing
our all of government effort as the
president's direction
to not only address uh the situation
that is upon us today uh that is
galvanizing our attention of course
but to really focus on critical
infrastructure
and what we can do to strengthen that
critical infrastructure across our
government
and to make it more resilient to these
types of attacks
and to raise awareness so that everyone
understands the need to prevent and be
in a position to respond
to these attacks and i'll turn it over
and i'll just say we may pull up our
deputy secretary here
in case uh go ahead peter secretary
orcas i'll follow up on what you just
said a moment ago the first chairman to
whom
uh the secretary referred to him a
moment ago said yesterday there should
be mandatory cyber security standards
for pipelines do you agree and is this
administration going to try to put those
in place
so our conversations within the
administration are ongoing
and have been underway with respect to
what measures
we need to take both administratively
and
uh of course in a companion effort uh
the legislature to see
how we can raise the cyber hygiene
across the country
yeah all right on a separate issue
secretary myers we have cameras today in
texas that are showing
humongous groups of dozens or hundreds
of migrants walking right into the
country so i'm curious
what you meant last week when you said
the border is closed
uh the board what i meant is precisely
that the border is closed
we are expelling single adults and
families under the title 42 authority
that rests with
the center for disease control
and we decided as an administration
in furtherance of the president's
direction to admit
minister our immigration laws of this
country in an
orderly and safe and humane way that we
will not expel
unaccompanied children mary secretary
graham
you just acknowledged the possibility of
a supply crunch can you give us a bit
more of a reality check here what kinds
of shortages
should americans be bracing for what
kind of disruption on gas prices
can americans expect um first let me
just be really clear the crunch
is in the areas that are affected by the
pipeline the main spurs of the pipeline
so that really is the southeast
it's about 70 percent of the supplies of
north carolina south carolina tennessee
georgia and especially southern virginia
are impacted the most and so those are
the areas that
we have the greatest concerns with and
because
of the um the fact that there's not a
whole lot of
other supply now this particular
pipeline also
supplies other states but there are
other pipelines that supply their states
as well so there's more diversity
in this particular region that's where
we're going to see the crunch
and this is why we are we know that we
have gasoline we just have to get it to
the right places
and that's why these next couple of days
i think will be challenging and we want
to encourage people
it's not that we have a gasoline
shortage it's that we have this supply
crunch
and that things will be back to normal
soon and then we're asking people not to
hoard
and know that every we are all over this
um thanks uh what does this say
about the fragility of our national
infrastructure that
one half could do this and could have
been worse if the hackers have gotten
into the operational system
attacks on our critical infrastructure
are not new
there are um different levels
of strength and resilience across the
critical
infrastructure enterprise and that is
why we are so focused
on making sure that the cyber hygiene
across the entire enterprise
is strengthened and remember in cyber
security one is only as strong as one's
weakest link
and therefore we are indeed focused on
identifying those weak links
working with those weak links in the
critical infrastructure enterprise as
well as throughout the private sector
and strengthening our country as a whole
this is not unique to the united states
thanks john secretary frank can you give
us a sense of the timeline on the jones
act waiver that we just heard from the
dot
about and and when will it go into
effect
actually you're the so this is the
contract waiver why
yeah yeah so uh um
so if i may uh when we receive a request
for
a waiver uh the department of
transportation
um engages in an an analysis
to determine whether any u.s flag
vessels
are available to deliver uh what is
needed
and if in fact they are then of course
they are called upon under the jones act
uh statute to deliver accordingly but
if there are u.s flag if there are not
u.s flags
available then we analyze uh the need
for foreign flag vessels and apply the
statutory requirements
uh correctly and of course in a
situation such as this
the work we already began precisely for
this reason
at the president's direction to be ready
and to be responsive with the urgency
that the situation would require
so we are on it as fast as possible is
there a timeline secretary
i know i know you're conducting a review
but what is the time so we're going to
move
in in lightning speed matt advisory
uh i had a question uh for secretary
granholm on behalf of a colleague
who couldn't be here uh not about the
colonial pipeline but a different one
um the state of michigan has ordered the
closure a pipeline
called line five with the deadline
tomorrow um
the question is has the white house or
the viper administration
or the former governor of michigan
current secretary granholm uh
if there's any position on the line five
if you guys are urging
the state of michigan to do anything one
way or the other yeah we we don't weigh
in on that and it's in court right now
um so that's where it sits it will be
decided in court
can you uh tell us what is the
feasibility of using rail cars to
transport fuel into the affected areas i
know that's being looked at
yeah um the d.o.t is looking at that and
so we'll have to wait till their
analysis
is done these
these are not easy solutions because um
there may or may not be the right uh
rail cars there may not or may not be
the
deep water ports available for the jones
act to be able to respond
so this particular area of the country
there
this is why we have doubled down on
ensuring that there's an ability to
truck
uh oil in gas in but it's
it's uh the pipe is the best way to go
and so that's why
um hopefully this company uh colonial
will
in fact uh be able to restore operations
by the end of the week as they have said
we're gonna do the last one back yeah i
actually have a question for each of you
i'll start with you secretary grant home
because ladies first
um obviously we have the acute issues
with the corneal pipeline
ransomware attack but looking more
holistically in a macro view how does
this speed up the efforts
at doe to move in more of a renewable
direction since this is going to have an
impact on people at the pump
yeah i mean we obviously are all in on
making sure that
we meet the president's goals of getting
to 100 clean electricity by 2035 and
net zero carbon emissions by 2050 and
um you know if you drive an electric car
this would not be affecting you clearly
um but
it's just it's another it's i don't want
to
this company um is acting in a
responsible way
uh they took their pipeline down so that
the ransomware
would not spread and so up to this point
they have
they're carefully reviewing so that
they're doing this in a responsible way
the broader issue is a very important
issue it's an
issue for the president's priority in
the american jobs plan
the issue of investing in a transmission
grid for
example so that you don't have the cyber
issues associated with it so there's a
lot of broader questions in this
um and we hope that we'll be able to see
that investment in
infrastructure that will facilitate
clean and renewable energy secretary
are you having any issues filling some
of these critical infrastructure jobs i
know this has been sort of a historic
problem inviting people who are
qualified to take on
mass scale cyber security for the
federal government that's a huge
undertaking
are you still having some of the issues
that we've seen sort of on and off
throughout history really in the history
of dhs
fil filling those positions with
qualified applicants
so um it's a very interesting question
so let me say we um
we launched this series of cyber
security sprints
uh several weeks ago our first cyber
security sprint
was on ransomware uh precisely because
of the threat the gravity
of the threat that that poses our second
sprint is precisely on
recruiting and retaining top cyber
security talent
bless you um uh top
talent and we're very focused on that
and we're very focused on also achieving
one of the president's critical
directives to reflect
a critical value which is that which is
that our cyber security talent
will achieve diversity equity and
inclusion
thanks thank you both all right thank
you thank you very much
all right okay um
i have a hard stop at three o'clock but
uh i wanted to of course bring the two
secretaries here and i know there's
other things going on in the world so we
will get to as many questions as we
possibly can
a couple of items at the top uh the
president announced
this morning or we announced this
morning that one million people
have signed up for health insurance
during the 2021 special enrollment
period since it started in february
the president highlighted this milestone
early this morning and that americans
have until august 15th
to gain affordable quality health
coverage through healthcare.gov
thanks to the american rescue plan four
out of five people can buy a plan
for less than ten dollars a month also
today
as just wrapped before this in our code
response team's
call well there i guess that was before
that uh with our nation's governors jeff
zions announced that jurisdictions will
receive close to 28 million doses
this week with two-thirds going to
states and the remainder to federal
channels he also announced additional
efforts to get america vaccinated many
of which you've seen out there
free rides for americans to vaccination
sites from lyft and uber by may 24th
and through july starting may 24th and
through july 4th
a new partnership with our federal
pharmacy partners to support on-campus
vaccination clinics
at some of the nation's largest
community colleges more resources
immediately available to states and
jurisdictions to fund on-the-ground
education efforts including personnel
costs and this money can go to things
like phone banking door-to-door
canvassing
pop-up vaccination sites and workplaces
and houses of worship which is
especially pivotal
at this stage we're in and as we await
hearing more from cdc and its
recommendations
the team has also reiterated that the
administration has already been working
to prepare
for youth vaccinations and ensuring we
can get supply out as quickly as
possible
a final item for all of you on the
situation in jerusalem and gaza
the president has been briefed daily on
developments in jerusalem and gaza he
just received another update
before i came out here from the national
security adviser
since last week he has directed his team
to engage
intensively with senior israeli and
palestinian officials
as well as leaders throughout the middle
east his team is communicating
a clear and consistent message in
support of de-escalation and that is our
primary focus
the president's support for israel's
security for its legitimate right to
defend itself
and its feeble is fundamental and will
never waver we condem ongoing rocket
attacks by hamas and other terrorist
groups including against jerusalem
we also stand against extremism that has
inflicted violence on both communities
jerusalem a city of such importance to
people of faith around the world
must be a place of coexistence is up to
the officials
residents and leaders to restore the
city to a place of calm
the president and his team will continue
to pursue the conditions for diplomacy
dialogue and de-escalation
and protection of civilians even as we
work together with our friends to deter
acts of violence
and terrorism we will also continue to
support a two-state solution
to the israeli-palestinian conflict that
is the only way
to ensure the just and lasting peace
that two peoples
have struggled to achieve we believe
palestinians
and israelis deserve equal measures of
freedom security dignity and prosperity
and u.s officials in recent weeks have
spoken candidly with israeli officials
about how evictions of palestinian
families
who have lived for years sometimes
decades in their homes and of
demolitions of these homes work against
our common interests
in achieving a solution to the conflict
in the coming days as muslims gather
with family and friends
to celebrate eid and join together
to mark the the beginning of shabbat let
us affirm that all people of faith
deserve to enjoy these important
celebrations
without fear of violence and work toward
peace and calm
for all with that armor go ahead thank
you uh
there's a new ap poll that shows that
just 11
of people who remain unvaccinated say
they definitely
will get the shot while 34 say they
definitely won't
uh are we getting to the point where the
well of persuadable folks is running dry
and what does this mean uh for the goal
of 70
by july 4th and then more broadly what
does it say about our country that
a meaningful share of americans don't
want the vaccine even as
so many other countries are so desperate
for it
well first let me say that the good news
and what we've seen in the data over the
past several months
is that the more people get vaccinated
the more confidence increases
and the more people then want to get
vaccinated so
we are still at war with this virus we
have a lot more work
left to do we set a goal as you noted a
new goal of getting to 70
of adults with at least one shot by july
4th and we're trying to build on
the lessons we have learned along the
way so our primary focus is on helping
make it easier to get vaccinated helping
workers
get time paid off uh get paid time off
more pop-up units and walk-up
sites including to be able to walk into
pharmacies and get vaccines
launching vaccines.gov and we're also
working to increase
vaccine confidence and this is goes to
the heart of what you're
talking about here now if you look back
to december january just when people
were just starting to get shots
uh the percentage of people who were
willing to get shots are incited about
getting shots in the country was below
50 percent
you know we have made great strides
since then great progress
and that is not as we look at the data
just by political persuasion or by
demographics
or even geography we've seen increases
in confidence
across groups we knew that it would
continue to get harder
as we proceeded along right as we got to
a point where the demand
the supply exceeded the demand but our
focus has been
on investing three billion dollars in
state and community-based organizations
ramping up targeted paid media efforts
in multiple languages
building a grassroots network of family
and friends so a lot of what we were
talking about about being able to have
door knockers and people making phone
calls canvassing
you know it reminds me a lot of what you
do as a grassroots organizer because
that's the phase we're in and what we're
going to need
at this point and ensuring equity uh
deploying more mobile units
expanding our community health center
program providing transportation
long story short are are are we have
always known we would reach this point
where it become more challenging
that's why we've been preparing to put
all of our resources many of our
resources in addressing that
and reaching the hardest hit and meeting
people where they are just briefly
follow on that
i know the president has said he might
not be the best spokesperson
uh for some of these groups but now is
this
the unvaccinated is getting smaller is
now the time to use
his weight and for the white house to uh
be
more out there and pushing people that
haven't got their shots
to get their shots well i think i i you
all hear from the president quite
frequently
on uh the importance of getting
vaccinated and the efficacy
of the vaccine and the uh the the
benefit of getting vaccinated and you
also hear multiple times a week from our
health and medical experts
so the point he's making is not that he
should hold back or pull back
in fact i think we've had him out there
quite frequently
it's that uh we can't become so
dependent
on having it be only uh the voice of a
president or even the voice of famous
people
out there people we think of as famous
as being the ones who will magically
turn the switch to
increased confidence what we've seen in
nearly every study
internally but also externally is that
it is local doctors
it is local medical professionals its
primary care physicians which is why
we've increased our partnership there
that is going to increase confidence in
communities which is also similar to
grassroots organizing right
if your neighbor says i got the vaccine
i had a little bit of a headache but i
feel pretty good and now i'm vaccinated
now i can go have dinner
outside and go to a restaurant that's
going to be more impactful
than seeing an uh in a television ad and
that's where we're putting our resources
go ahead and india thank you jen um how
is the white house responding to states
that are planning to end the special
unemployment benefits
are you just going to let that happen
the special enrollment benefits
unemployment benefits oh
uh sorry i didn't hear the last part of
what you were saying look
ultimately it's up to states to make
that determination
uh what we've seen in the data and i've
seen we've seen the explanations
that have been uh put out there by some
leaders
in states and some leaders even in
washington uh and they have blamed uh
300 checks that are going out to
americans as the reason
for uh a an unemployment an unemployment
an employment report unemployment report
that was lower than expectations uh
we're not actually seeing that in the
data as the root cause
and what we've seen in the data as the
root cause are
a range of issues including primarily
the fact that we're continuing to fight
a pandemic
and there are a lot of implications of
that one of them is people being fearful
about being safe
if they're not vaccinated one is child
care these are a lot of issues that
we're working to address
but in our view we still have a
disproportionate number of
people in a range of communities a high
level of unemployment among african
americans latino americans
we still there are still people who need
assistance and we're not seeing this as
a root cause or a major factor
in people not seeking work would you be
specifically telling states that are
looking to end these benefits
is there a specific message to such
states i think i just conveyed it's up
to the states but
again we're not seeing uh this is the
root cause driver of people not seeking
work of course we're gonna see
anecdotal examples we certainly
recognize that but what we're seeing
across the board is that
the cause is largely the pandemic and
the impacts of the pandemic
whether that is people being concerned
about their health and safety if they're
not yet vaccinated
child care challenges and that's what
we're working
to address and just one more on the
president's trip to michigan next week
and we understand uh he plans to visit a
ford uh electric uh vehicle plant
uh both general motors and ford are
planning to build
uh electric vehicles in mexico as you're
aware um
we're just we're curious to know if the
president
agrees with the united auto workers
union that government subsidies for such
uh vehicles should not really go to uh
cars that are made overseas
well first i would say that we're
honored uh that
we're we're looking forward to going to
visit
the ford motor company and to preview
see the f-150 lightning and the exciting
technologies that make it possible
and the president's going there because
electrifying america's
best-selling vehicle electrifying
america's vehicles is
an important part of his priorities and
important part of his
focus um that's why he's going to visit
the site but i don't think i'm going to
weigh in on that further go ahead peter
let me ask you the state of california
right now is projecting a budget surplus
of roughly 76 billion dollars such that
the governor of that state is
now wanting to hand uh to deliver checks
of roughly 600
to everybody making less than 75 000 as
you know this all comes against the
backdrop of those 350 billion dollars
from the american rescue plan being
handed out to states and and local
governments so did the white house
overestimate how much money would be
needed california itself gets 42
billion dollars out of the deal well
first let me say that
the way that the money was determined is
by statute
it requires treasury to allocate funds
to states based in part on the average
number of unemployed
people in states in the last three
months of 2020. so
that's how the determination was made
from state to state so for california or
any state across the country
it was based on the final three months
of unemployment uh in 2020.
here's what we still know uh that
there's a
broad and flexible list of guidelines
for how these funds can be used
including to put public servants back to
work
ramp up the effectiveness of coveted
response and vaccination programs
help workers train for and secure good
paying jobs
those are all needs that exist in
california and exist
in states across the country and as i
noted in response to the earlier
question
there are still millions of people out
of work in this country
and still millions of people who are
serving in jobs
like police officers firefighters
educators
who could benefit from this assistance
that's going out but given that based on
those numbers obviously we now recognize
that california has much more money than
you anticipated should that raise any
questions
for critics of how much money the
president wants to spend
on the upcoming proposals including the
infrastructure plan as it relates to
social programs
well first i would say the core of the
infrastructure of the american jobs plan
is on rebuilding infrastructure around
the country that we all know
is outdated whether that is bridges
across the country whether that is
roads and railways that have long
there's agreement
among democrats and republicans
including some many in congress that
that needs to be invested those
investments are necessary
uh things like redoing our lead pipes
around the country which will
ensure kids have clean drinking water
will also create
jobs so what that proposal is about is
about
modernizing uh outdated infrastructure
doing it in a way that brings us to the
21st century and helps us compete with
china uh that is a
big long-term investment and one that um
you know the president certainly stands
stands by i wanna let other people ask
the questions let me ask one last one
which is
there's a big vote here in washington
though that's gonna take place tomorrow
morning among the house republicans
right do you believe that at elise
stefanik's likely election
to house leadership will diminish or
will help
the prospect for bipartisanship in
washington
well peter as probably won't surprise
you we're not spending much time here
determining an outcome of or predicting
an outcome of i should say or
uh or analyzing the impact of
inter-party fighting within the
republican party we will leave that to
them
to work out among themselves will it or
will it not affect your
you guys are fighting for bipartisanship
so will her
likely new position help or hurt that
effort
at no point is our effort to fight for
bipartisanship
about uh being an arbiter or a mediator
between inter-party fighting in the
republican party
you know the president has invited
tomorrow same day as the vote he's
invited bipartisan leaders to come
to the white house to have a discussion
about
where we can find common ground and how
we can work together
and that's an example of how he feels
he can represent the american people
pursue
an agenda that would help benefit people
whether they're
they voted for him or not uh so we'll
let the inter-party squabbling
happen at the table over here and at the
table over here
or or a smaller table in the oval office
we're going to have a discussion about
how we can work together
uh go ahead thank you two topics all
real quick is white house rethinking
their opposition to new
pipeline projects since one really
important one goes offline and
gas stations start running dry i
wouldn't say we look at it as
in through that prism peter we look at
it we analyze both
the impact the economic impact as well
as the environmental impact and
that will certainly remain the case but
we look at different each pipeline
project
individually environmental impact if the
solution for this
pipeline going offline is for oil
producers to start using
rail cars and oil tankers as uh floating
storage
and for the epa to start letting gas
stations sell lower quality fuel that is
not
as clean burning how is president
showing us climate leadership
well peter i think what the president's
trying to do in this moment in time
is ensure that the american people know
that we're going to work to address this
current challenge
and that he is going to use all of the
assets
and resources at his disposal in
departments and you saw that as evidence
from what our
secretary of homeland security talked
about what our secretary of energy
talked about
to address to address these current
challenges and he doesn't want people
on the east coast and the southeast uh
to uh worry he doesn't want them to
uh to uh he wants them to have an
understanding of
the fact that the government is all over
this and we're working to address it
uh and address their needs as quickly as
possible and quickly on pandemic is the
cdc making it harder for you guys
to convince people to get vaccines and
to wear masks when they've created this
impression that up to 10 percent of
covet transmission occurs outdoors even
though there's this new york times
report now where they say
there's not a single documented proven
and coveted infection anywhere in the
world from casual outdoor interactions
well i believe dr welinski addressed
this in the senate hearing
this morning and she pointed to a
collection of scientific studies
that set that number that they relied on
that set that number at less than 10
percent
we know as more people get vaccinated
there will be less and less need for
certain restrictions and the cdc has
said they will continue to evaluate
the science and update their
recommendations as they have already
begun
doing and so that's what we will be
relying on moving forward and as we have
been but they did
still they took the study they chose to
put it as part of their guidance and so
i guess my last question would be uh
the then president-elect said in january
i've always said that the biden-harris
administration
will lead with science and truth which
one is it here
well again peter we we know that outdoor
transmission is rare the cdc has said
that themselves
i would certainly refer you to them on
their uh and the scientists and experts
there
uh the scientists the the leaders in uh
data analysis
to get to the heart of what they look at
but this the
dr wolenski referred to several studies
uh that uh
that provided that data and then
information and that's what they look at
there
go ahead mary on the pipeline uh the
president has talked about needing to
give financial support
to protect critical infrastructure but
his infrastructure plan doesn't
explicitly outline any funding for cyber
security so
what kind of investments if any in cyber
security would the president like to see
included
in an infrastructure bill to prevent
future attacks like this
well as we work and have discussions
with congress and as we finalize details
of the american
jobs plan we are talking about investing
in critical infrastructure and
you know we've looked at for example
what we saw
in texas and the need to better protect
and better prepare for
even events like that weather events
where infrastructure could have been
better protected
and certainly ensuring that cyber
security is a part of that conversation
is on the mind of the president and one
he'll look forward to uh
his team having with members and with uh
staff on the hill moving forward
when you take a big picture look at this
you know cyber security experts have
been warning
for years about attacks like this and
yet we haven't seen the government
take steps to be able to prevent them
why should americans
be confident that this time will be any
different
well i think it's important to remember
this is a private sector company
this isn't a federal government entity
and we are working closely with them
both to stay closely coordinated ensure
that they are getting the assistance and
counsel they need
but also we are working through an
interagency process with a great deal of
urgency i promise you coming from the
president
to ensure that we are taking steps uh
through
steps from the federal government to
plan for all contingencies
uh this was a private sector uh action
as secretary granholm said uh of a
company to
take down uh their uh pipeline uh
because of the ransomware
this is ransomware that has been out
there for some time we have
in this gov in this in this white house
and in this government we have ensured
that there is increased cooperation
between the public and private sector
but a big lesson from this is the need
for all companies to harden the cyber
their cyber security
apparatus and to ensure that they are
protecting themselves
even as we are working as a government
to plan for contingencies
and ensure that across the federal
government we have all the necessary
protections in place
the president said yesterday that the
hack was traced back to russia but there
was no evidence that the russian
government
was involved is that still your
understanding and if so what
responsibility does russia bear if i
need to deal with these actors
well the president also said that his
intelligence community has not made a
full assessment yet which remains the
case
uh but also uh that uh given that this
entity
that the fbi had concluded or you know
given attributed i should say with the
attack
uh was located uh in russia that the
hope that country has a responsibility
to uh to act responsibly
uh but again we'll wait for our uh
intelligence community to make a full
assessment uh before we
uh have more to convey about it go ahead
nancy
we are expecting new inflation numbers
out tomorrow and i'm wondering if the
gas price surge in the continuous
commodity surge like lumber is changing
the administration's outlook
on inflation well let me first say that
of course the federal reserve i would
point you to them to speak to or provide
analysis or speculation on anything
as it relates to inflation or the impact
of
certain external actions i will say as
we've said in here before but
we'll reiterate that of course we take
uh the possibility of inflation quite
seriously
as you know actions that have been taken
to date or proposals that have been made
uh most economic analysts have believed
that it will have a temporary a
transitory impact
but in terms of analysis on current
events i would point you to the federal
reserve
go ahead yes jen the president assured
governors today will be enough vaccine
for
all americans what about americans
overseas there's a bipartisan groups who
are pleading with this administration
to help them get vaccinated it's
impractical
for them to fly back to the united
states so are you looking into this
anything that the
administration can do well um
we certainly uh join as a veteran of the
state department i can restate that
we are quite focused on the health
safety well-being of
americans living all around the world we
have not historically provided private
health care
for americans living overseas so that
remains our policy um but i don't have
anything to predict in terms of what may
be ahead
there's one quick housekeeping item for
us in the room here
why was the pool not invited in to the
president's remarks
today what was different about today
than any other day for the pool
well the entirety of the remarks were
live streamed for
everyone in the media whether they're
sitting here or sitting at home or
sitting in a bureau
could see or the american people could
see including the engagements with
governors
questions and answers with governors so
i don't know that you can be more
transparent than that
but is this going to be the norm now or
was this a one-off i think this was a
setup where you had multiple governors
on a stage
and it was just something we're ensuring
it was live stream available to
everybody was the choice that we made
uh go ahead yes thank you uh if
congress can't get together on a
bipartisan january 6th commission
is the president willing to appoint one
on his own
well i know they're still working
through this and there is strong support
among many members of congress in a
commission which obviously is something
we also support from this administration
so
i'm not going to stand here and predict
failure uh if
uh or get ahead of that process that's
ongoing relatedly and that this goes to
the uh liz
cheney police department thing sure is
the president concerned
that um there are so many republicans
who are still going along with the lie
that the election was uh was rigged or
illegitimate somehow well we're
focused on what we can entirely control
from here
and what the president's focus is on is
leading by example
is governing for all americans and is
hopefully reinstilling trust in not just
government
and the federal government but also in
democracy we don't expect that to happen
overnight
but that is a central objective of him
of his presidency
and that's how he and we feel we can
best combat
uh the misinformation uh that is
continues to be out there
go ahead go in here a couple questions
about the meetings this week with
republicans sure are members of both
parties um is it
can you guys give us a sense when they
come back to the capitol they
you know tell us sort of what some of
those issues are that they're discussing
what is your perspective on is the
number one issue
the size of the package at this point is
it how to pay for it
or is it specific proposals that are in
it you mean in terms of disagreement
between
that issue well i think it's
pretty clear that most people not only
in the country but also even in
elected office believe that our
infrastructure is outdated
believe that we need to create jobs
believe that we need to compete with
china
those are all areas where frankly
democrats and republicans
have worked together for decades and and
we are working on some different pieces
of legislation
in congress now uh so a lot of the
disagreement is around how to pay for it
president has proposed how to pay for
all of his proposals
uh there's obviously a difference of
opinion on that uh but
i think that's probably one of the
central pieces and then just on the
timing of this i know you have
in the in previous briefings not really
talked about the timing too much
people are using memorial day or the end
of may i've talked about it many times
but summer time right i said progress by
memorial day and uh hope to sign it by
the summer
and when asked about progress i just
want to understand what that means
so does that mean by memorial day the
talks will stop and
um the president or democrats will try
to move forward or will the bipartisan
discussions continue
i don't think we can make that
assessment quite yet anita i think what
he's looking at what we're looking at is
we want to see
if there's an opportunity to work
together but it doesn't mean we stop
then
uh it just means we will uh we will be
able to assess at that point where
things sit where we go from there but
as you know from covering these uh
sausage making bill making policy making
extravaganzas
uh usually there's talks right until the
very moment when something's passed so i
would expect they would continue until
that moment
to clarify just what steve was saying
was that was the entirety of the
president's remarks with the governors
the virtual march
live stream is that what you are i
believe it was
i mean it's hard to tell when the where
you're not on online
or we were watching from here and then
the briefing began so i couldn't
we didn't start the briefing until it
concluded uh okay go ahead in the back
so uh tomorrow's meeting obviously you
want to find areas of common ground
what specifically is on the agenda what
issues are you going to be talking about
what do you hope is going to be the
outcome of that meal sure well when we
first say that
there are a lot of ways to approach a
meeting like this as you know
uh and the way the president is thinking
about it is that
you know you could spend the entire
meeting talking about areas of
disagreement there's no shortage of
those
uh or you could spend it seeking
opportunity for common ground
and he's going to choose the latter and
so his hope is that
this can be a discussion about uh where
we
can find common agreement where there's
an opportunity to work together moving
forward
there has been a discussion about
infrastructure investing in
infrastructure
the importance of modernizing
infrastructure there's been different
proposals out there obviously we also
have a meeting on
thursday with a number of republican
senators to discuss
exactly that i'm certain that creating
jobs
and that will be a part of this
discussion uh but also
uh there's areas where we've worked
together whether it's or there's shared
concern
whether it's addressing the
semiconductor chip shortage or
uh ensuring uh that we are preparing our
the american workforce to compete i know
we expect that
members will come with different items
on their agenda and
uh the president just looks forward to
having a constructive meeting because he
knows that
uh they're common values among americans
and that if we just spend all of our
time
competing and snipping at each other we
can't help address the challenges we're
all facing
two quick things is the georgia floyd
policing act part of that conversation
tomorrow
obviously the president said a pretty
tight deadline for that
part of the movement so i was wondering
if that would be something
there are negotiations as you know that
are ongoing on a bipartisan uh manner i
expect once the meeting concludes we'll
give you a sense of what the topics are
that ended up coming up in the meeting
and secondly uh you know it's been
born three months almost four months
since president office uh
i think this is the first time he's
gonna have spoken to congressman
mccarthy
uh he spoke with him around the joint
address as well when he was there why
just sit down with them all together now
for the first time it's been a while
why is it taking this long in his turn
to do that well i would say i don't have
the numbers in front of me but there has
been
have been dozens of members of both
parties here sitting in the oval office
having meetings directly with the
president
and far more than that probably in the
hundreds having engagements and
discussions with senior members
of the white house team this is an
opportunity to sit down with leaders
from both parties have a discussion
again about common ground
how we can work together moving forward
he did talk to him around the
joint address but the president also
knows from being in the senate for 36
years you're going to work with and have
discussions with a range of members
hence we have the meeting on thursday
to do that exactly okay i'm going to
wrap this up in a second go ahead matt
uh i just want to follow
quickly on on the mccarthy aspect yeah
because tomorrow he is having a vote
with house republicans to oust liz
cheney because i've heard that
and now just shortly after that he is
coming to the white house to meet with
president biden and
does he not feel that what mccarthy is
doing just before he comes to the white
house is
undermining his presidency his
legitimacy
i mean does he not intuit any of that or
is he
completely overlooking that to to meet
with him and did he consider not having
mccarthy come
no here's what i can assure you the
focus of this meeting is not on the
future of the republican party
uh they are neither seeking nor is he
offering his perspective on that
um and it is not going to nor will they
resolve
the identity of the party who they are
and what they will stand for
that won't be resolved in this meeting
uh the president knows that you have to
work with
leaders with members of both parties
you're going to have disagreements and
maybe you're going to find some areas of
common ground
so hopefully in this meeting they can
have a discussion and decide
hey are we all for infrastructure
investment do we think we should all
create do we all think we should create
more jobs
are the roads and rails and bridges in
your state or your district
outdated well let's figure out how to
work together moving forward and that's
what he
hopes to focus the meeting on quickly
just for a colleague who couldn't be
here
um you had mentioned earlier about
trying to instill confidence in the
vaccine
is the white house doing anything on the
flip side
where there's misinformation from from
pundits from
outlets from entertainers whoever to try
to combat that misinformation
reaching out to those people those
outlets or anything to try to
push back on any misinformation around
vaccinations
certainly we do and now there are
different layers of that
right as you all know we're not shy if
we disagree with something in your
reporting hopefully we do that in a
classy way on our best days uh
but we certainly do that there's a lot
of information that's flowing out there
and
it's not all that in misinformation is
mal intent and we don't always see it
that way
what our focus though is on is ensuring
i mean we're investing three billion
dollars right in
uh empowering and engaging local voices
also in a paid media campaign of our own
ensuring that accurate information is
coming
not just through paid channels or even
earned media channels but also through
local trusted voices and that is what we
have seen
uh is the most effective in breaking
through i'm just gonna go because i know
you're not here all the time so we'll
end with you
go ahead thank you so much so i have two
very quick runs the first one
is i want to look forward past tomorrow
to the thursday meeting sure senator
uh shelly moore capital of west virginia
has said that 586 billion
her proposal for infrastructure is a
starting point she seems open to
negotiation even ahead of that meeting
has the president considered maybe
meeting
halfway on the hard infrastructure that
republicans sort of want to narrow
in on or is he still kind of working in
what way he wants to make that work
well the president is quite open to a
range of vehicles and mechanisms for
moving his ideas forward
and he has said from the beginning that
uh he is open
uh he is open to having that discussion
open to compromise
uh appreciates uh the fact that the
republicans led by senator capito in
this case
have put forward a proposal and
negotiation and compromise is about
exactly that
so uh that's encouraging uh and
hopefully that will be
uh that will set the tone for the
meeting on thursday my last very quick
one is about the markets
i work for cheddar news that's what we
do yes so
looking at the market today things are
going well but i actually want to talk
about a different type of market which
is the crypto market
the crypto market has been incredibly
volatile no one
is surprised by that but it has also
surged right we've seen
dogecoin kind of a fake currency do
incredibly well people have made a lot
of money
is the president at all concerned about
the the opportunity for huge gains and
huge losses
and therefore looking at regulations
similar to what we see with the sec
for that crypto space because it is
still very unregulated
it's an excellent question and we
certainly refer to our regulatory
agencies and to our secretary of
treasury on
oversight and not just oversight i
should say and on looking at in their
advice and counsel on the markets
including the cryptocurrency markets
thanks so much everybody
you